got some breaking news now concerning a
London Bridge and the mantra Balaton
police have said they are dealing with
an incident at London Bridge and that
follows unconfirmed reports that shots
have been fired at the Metropolitan
Police is tweeted say we're currently
dealing with an incident at London
Bridge please stand by for updates
images on social media show a large
police presence on the bridge traffic
has been brought to a standstill by it
and we will of course bring you more
information on that as soon as we have
it but the Metropolitan Police say they
are dealing with an incident at London
Bridge there have been unconfirmed
reports that shots have been fired